hello i'm going to start my presentation
this presentation is a multi-language
data wrangling conversational agent
my name is anton antonov i'm a senior
research scientist at
ascendo data llc um
i'm a long time user of north america i
work for wolfram research
i'm an applied mathematician but i brand
myself as a data scientist or
senior data scientist senior research
scientist in the last 10 years
so uh this presentation
is um this is abstract
um this is what what is this about uh
we want to do rapid specification of
data wrangling workflows using natural
language commands
the reason for this is that we have too
many packages in languages with their
own
kind of way of doing data wrangling in
their own inducing clusters and syntax
and so we want to actually uh speed up
uh on this uh the deployment of the same
workflows across uh
different systems i mean these are this
is the longer motivation here
but the thing is that we want to
to be to be more effective i very often
need to use multiple systems in order to
uh to be able to be um adequate in my
work when it comes to data wrangling so
a system like that would be beneficial
so
um i did mention several uh packages and
uh
languages in the beginning so
we're going to be looking into julia
julia
r and python i mean you can see i have
several python installations but i guess
we're going to use only one of them
so uh because the title was uh
speech conversational agent so i did
actually think
that i can be further ahead with uh
using speech recognize and actually
having
uh uh voice voice to text voice to
commands to data wrangling code
translation
the thing is that i really have hard
time this is from
america apple is even worse uh so
i have hard time you know my commands my
pronunciation to be
parsed correctly or the way i want and
even native english
speakers they also i mean the results
are
much better but but not great so
um this actually brings me to the
to the point what is the ideal end
result and i i'm going to show it to you
i think
this is probably the most important part
of my talk uh
the ideal end result so i opened a new
notebook i'm going to zoom it so
uh it can be see it better i'm
converting into
dsl mode and now
uh with this dlc mode i can have this
cells
which let me uh do uh stuff like say
us use the uh df
it's like data frame
and so here i group
by species
and then i want to see the counts
sorry so what this does
here is just produced uh mathematical
code
right and so uh i mean if i evaluate
this
uh you're going to to get the the
results but
i am targeting uh data scientists or
data scientists wannabes
um like engineers data analysts managers
uh basically they these people
they want to eat data sciences too they
want to generate code and then
to kind of see how the code looks like
and then eventually uh
do something further with it uh like uh
utilize it and modify it better
so this here i'm going to uh using the
same commands i'm going to change the
target
when i say target i mean which package
and language
i'm going to be translating to so let's
go to
tie divers
so let me spell here
so um the diverse and yeah generates i
caught and if i do
exactly the same thing like i'm going to
copy and paste
exactly the same thing here and if i say
uh
something like i know uh let me see i
because i mentioned julia
and let me see uh you should i mean you
already
kind of got the idea so um actually july
is a little bit slower
and this actually produced um
produced a valid response let me just
transform it uh to mathematica form
if i did this uh if i did this in python
right
python is like a first class citizen it
looks like in uh
in mathematica so uh with python pandas
uh this is going to uh look much better
i mean much better i don't need to make
the conversion which i did
and so this actually executed let me put
the object here
so yeah you can see this is an object
which python produced okay so i'm just
going to make a couple of
more cells just for the sake of time i'm
going to copy and paste
some cells i prepared beforehand
like say for example here this workflow
create a recommender with jf titanic
um apply lsi functions idf and cosign
and recommend by profile mail
this is going to be recognized as a
as a recommended workflow so this uh
cells here this dsl
uh cells in this uh notebook
uh very clever enough whatever is the
functionality behind it it's clever
enough to figure out
what um which type of uh
workflows i'm dealing with and uh for
example i mean this was a classification
and something uh is something else i was
just
listening to some neural network and
some uh classification
uh classification uh lectures i mean
this is basically producing a classifier
all right so uh back to this um
what exactly was happening with what i
was showing you here
so uh i do in the mathematical notebook
cell
i do have a function which uh calls
external process
uh on my system um and so
which calls the language raku raku is
the descendant of
pearl uh raku was also known as pearl
six but they renamed it three four five
months ago
raku has this um domain specific
language
parasaur grammar you know interpreter
which interprets
english uh uh commands into code
and this interpretation is specified by
the targets i have multiple targets
when i execute something like say julia
right or python
uh you you saw how the the notebook sell
uh
here right i mean these are basically uh
this uh this functionality is clever
enough from the target knowing that this
is our code you know to produce an
asl and then from this uh we use
external execute
and we you know we call the language
the corresponding language so uh
at this point you know you know this is
the ideal end result
but in order to make um serious
development
effort for this end result and to
be able to be effective in this effort
we need to decide what exactly we're
going to do
quite a lot of assumptions and
simplifying consumptions
and invariants to be figured out about
the workflows about
probably the users and definitely about
the data
so i'm concentrating on data frames data
frames are just tabular data
and this is what is the precise
definition of the data we're considering
tabular data or simple collections of
tabular data this means
lists of data sets or
associations of data sets so
uh this um this diagram
explains uh shows fairly well what
exactly
is uh what exactly is uh are the
workflows
which are being considered so we load
the data we get it like say just df star
wars whatever i was using in my examples
there's some way for me to
access load it into the system then we
do some
um summarization some other queries
we scratch our head and thinking is this
does this need transforming or not
if it doesn't well we exported or
assigned to something else if it does we
go through this
uh transformation steps all of the steps
here
are optional so you can go through this
uh you can do the operations in this uh
rectangles but you can also just skip it
so
um yeah we might filter the data then
split it then transform it
transform the groups produced by the
splitting combine the results
and do some reshaping and then we go
back to this one here
as i said we can skip some of these
elements for me splitting the data means
either taking subsets of the rows or
subsets of the columns
the filtering obviously can belong to
the transformation group but this is a
little bit
more like how do you specify the the
workflow so
um this is the so this pattern here is
the so-called uh
split transform combined pattern in uh
the r community it was introduced by
hadley wickham
uh he is the author of uh uh deploy
which is part of tie divorce you might
have heard about these libraries
uh this article is important but this is
also something people do
from for very long time like say
parallel combine
does exactly exactly this we split the
data
we transform the data and we combine it
and just by definition just what
parallel functionalities in mathematica
do same say when you do
stuff with sql but these are this is
more or less
the um uh the the workflows we i'm uh
going to be programming against there
shown here
so obviously this can be done not just
for say um machine learning workflow so
data
data wrangling workflows you can see
here this is these are natural commands
about epidemiological
uh simulations this is a special moment
so this is a magnetic code which does
this
calculations and transformations and you
know we're doing this
conference online because of covet 19.
so um how this is done
so i mean here you can see i did mention
monarch pipelines you can see for this
sequence of frequents use df star wars
group by special species and counts
so you can see this is the julia code
the mathematical code is here
right and the monadic code
by ah or tie diverse right it's here you
notice this pipeline symbol uh here in
the previous uh previous slide the
pipeline symbol i'm using is this
long right our double right hour this
here is that peculiar combination of
form
of characters so uh
except for our tigers in this in this
data frame you'll see that
all of these operations they do have
this uh
assignment right and then this obj
variable appears on the right hand side
so
you can probably skip skip this
assignment
and this uh you know um mandatory
appearance of that variable and use this
pipeline pipeline type of syntax
which is more economical also fairly
concise
uh i don't for me this is not just
cosmetic uh
feature this is actually um a very um
a very um uh serious assumption or
actually i mean not assumption i know
that i'm going to be producing code like
that in this kind of shape and form
and this allows me to do uh to speed up
the implementation to do one line
interpreters to make the translations
better this here it's a slightly
different
example one of the reasons and this is
more um not just for monarch pipelines
but
one of the reasons i'm doing this is
that
imagine you have something very simple
like this rename
species as var1 right species if i show
you
uh you have star wars i mean species is
one of the
uh it should be one of the variables
here right somewhere here
all right so now i just want to rename
one one particular column into something
else
and you know this might take quite a lot
of typing and entering of you know
code and not just in mafia mark in
anything else
all right so um this um
this shows the development cycle like we
pick a certain
certain problem domain like say data
wrangling or classification or a
commander so whatever i was discussing
earlier
and um after a while if we get
experienced in this
we actually can produce two types of
monarchs i would say one is a software
monarch
the other one is um grammar grammar of
sentences and grammar
at least the way grammars i describe
them or see them described
they have very uh very good monadic
monadic structure so at some point
we married the two we made this this
domain specific language
in some natural language like english or
bulgarian or russian or whatever
is being connected in some way with say
this software monitor
package or library in whatever language
you have in mind like say python java
and so forth
and um this is the single line
interpreters is the first thing to do
after a while we actually need to be
able to not just interpret one command
but look into the say the whole series
of commands
and at this point and actually before
that but
you know also here but we might be
thinking about making an actual
conversational agent from a finite
state machine perspective this fsm is
finding state machine
um this actually as i said
you can apply the final state machines
in this stage too it really depends uh
it really depends what exactly is your
point of view
but you can if you have done all this
you can actually hook up
some some speech to text converter like
say
this speech recognize which i was
showing earlier
you know which is part of wolfram
language or you know like alexa siri and
so forth
right notice that um this here this kind
of system
it's uh it needs to be designed to fail
right meaning unit tests uh extremely
important
at all points you need to know when
failure occurs and how to address it
and so yeah i've been basically just
explain that and this is the slide with
the rigorous testing
i was mentioning so um for this
particular project
uh i have done several types of unit
tests very far from complete
but roughly speaking the tests are two
types the parsing and the translator
tests right like can we parse the actual
sentences
and the other is what functionality wise
you know like say
this uh whatever i was showing earlier
here like is this actually the correct
transformation when i
execute this right does this is this
actually correct so
like is it does this the parsing here
does it produce the the results we
expect
so uh again you know like unit tests are
important imagine i changed the grammar
rules in some way and then basically
half of this correctness tests fail and
this means what you know
with some kind of minor change in my
grammars i have
broken up quite a lot of functionalities
all right so uh here uh i just want to
go back to the data wrangling
this is a more concretely speaking like
this
fairly complicated or i think it is
fairly complicated
series of natural language commands
like say we filter we do some you know
selection
we do some grouping some replacement and
so forth this summarize
actually this is not a trivial this is
not a trivial command
let me see can i demonstrate this uh
summarizing summarizing elements of uh
summarizing the columns of groups it's a
and this just as accurate i just want to
show you
and i need to because i copy and paste
it i need to replace
this here all right so
that's discouraging okay i messed it up
well so okay i was impatient and uh
and kind of messed up the
let me let me do this
i mean i hope something was produced and
i guess i need to execute this
in order to see the result all right so
the
what what is happening here i um
filtered the original
data frame the roles of the original
data frame so the bar field to be
greater than 27
grouped by home world and then um
and then um replace some of the missing
values
and um this here it's uh
each of the groups have been summarized
uh
for each of the groups the columns um
mass and height have been summarized
using this functions mean and medium
i mean i don't need to use i don't need
to use of course i don't need to use
two functions i can use any any number
of functions here any number of columns
so anyway uh this is actually as i said
a relatively complicated uh
transformation um of course the other
thing to do
uh is to do joints with other
with other tables so here with the table
of data frame data set star wars film
films i joined it with the
star wars data using using
name as a joining joining factor and
then
yeah i mean the results presumably
something we expect this is
actually pretty straightforward just
going to show what is exactly here with
uh
yeah we have names and films uh we can
of course address different
joints like inner join left join uh semi
join and so forth
crosstabulation i mentioned it as a part
of
this diagram let me see did i load this
diagram yeah
so crosstabulation is uh is here right
this is actually one of the one of the
shaping um
um reshaping functionalities we're
targeting
um and yeah in my opinion very important
feature to do
uh it can be done through by grouping
but crosstabulation is somewhat
different
this uh hymn it's um
this actually shows uh one of the
decisions i made
i didn't want to i didn't want to
program
a separate month involved from language
for data wrangling
i wanted to use vol from language as
this
i have done some other mods like that
like for example
uh neural networks the way you construct
them in uh
in the wolfram language they do form a
monarch it's not explicitly discussed
but it is actually
they do form a they do have monarchic
organization and design so similarly uh
i was
i'm hoping and i want to use wolfram
language
without any kind of uh additional um
additional code or packages as this so
for some of the functions like
crosstabulation
and pivoting i need to use some package
or packages or
resource functions but in general i've
been pretty much adhering to this now
one of the drawbacks of this is let's
say
if i want to make this formula here
which refers to some of the columns in
the data set
i mean it's a little bit hard to specify
i mean i obviously this specification
the way you see it like that
it's going to work in outer diverse not
in our base but you know what i diverse
is going to to do
in my family i need to adjust this and
of course i can i can
just enter this expression here when you
see this kind of backticks this means
that i can put any formula or any
expression
from the host language in this natural
language description
so this is something i need to resolve
and address in one way or the other but
so far i mean it's it is uh it is uh
down to a useful some useful stage
another thing
which is um um an interesting uh point
of view
and it's uh relates to to the type of
data we're considering
tabular data or collections of tabular
data
is what if i have multiple group by
statements what is exactly happening
you can see here that after i have
grouped by species and
say made some calculation over the
groups then i say
group by homeworld now am i supposed to
group the
subgroups or what now you can see that
i'm not grouping the subgroups i'm
actually flattening
flattening the data uh first and then i
do the group by
so this is actually also something which
is done in uh
in this package addie player or tie
reverse
uh again this actually it is it is for
the sake of convenience and it does make
sense
uh it is uh another thing to to mention
here
is that of course you can group by
different by a sequence of variables
like meaning
you can you can group by several
variables but if you have these groups
by group bias one after the other you
have this kind of evolutional
type of uh perspective
the other is that in order to do that my
my parser should be
actually aware that the previous group
by happened
so when i was saying that this was one
by line interpreter
it's well actually does have some
awareness of the sequence of commands
now
if you just immediately start with some
variable which is already grouped
well there's no way just to know about
it but you know ideally you'll be
getting uh
errors if you if you run that so one of
the
things out here when i discuss this by
collaborators and friends um
[Music]
and also not friends uh is that my data
wrangling is too complicated for this
approach
now i agree i mean i don't think this
approach
whatever i'm showing and it's not just
my my programming of it in general
i think it addresses more like 70 to 60
60 70 and at most 75 percent of my needs
when it comes to
data to data wrangling type of
transformations nevertheless
using these patterns uh they do actually
help
knowledge transfer they do have uh help
with um
project management the reasons for for
people who use wolfram language there
too
for to state this is that um one is the
lisp curse
uh and strongly encourage you to look it
up if you haven't heard about the list
curse
the other is what voltron language
targets deeply hierarchical data
and so that's actually kind of different
from
um i mean because of this
in general the know-how and the
transformations
they're much more they're much more
complicated
than if you restrain yourself only to
tabular data
so um this is a complicated workflow
which is related to the previous slide
just to illustrate the streamlining
so this is dance combat data set
basically uh
four data sets of this compact quartet
right four data sets which have the same
descriptive statistics
like say same linear regression same
mean same medium etc
now you can see what this data set is
actually very inconvenient to to work
with
i mean if you want to plot it what
exactly do you do so here i have done
this series of commands in which i
convert the whole thing to long form
then i separate actually let me execute
this
so um this here uh ideally
let me actually execute the show the
individual
uh steps here so this is the combat data
set
i with the conversion to long form and
this is i'm using
one of my packages here called data
reshape uh
i'm moving the metadata the
the column names they become data then i
split with this command separate
uh separate data column i split the
this happens often this people conflate
data into their meta like they could
convey several variables they put them
into
into the column names of the tables so
as i said discount on so on so now i'm
splitting this variable column the
second one
into variable and set then i convert
this to
a white form and now in a position to
to kind of after i convert this to white
form you can see i
actually now in a position to plot the
to plot the
the data set so ideally yeah this
i am not going to zoom it so um
all right so i'm not sure did i mention
this already but
you know this obviously this should be
we should be able to handle misspellings
uh so like i mean i misspelled filter
here it
also uh tabulates right i mean if i
uh type in this in it's you know
also if you use uh any kind of voice
recognition system
this this is actually a must i think is
what
which i haven't done is actually spell
checking for
data frame names and um column names
this is in my i mean as i mentioned
uh i mean i can i
i have uh this can be done in different
languages
uh if i have done this for programming
languages obviously i can do it for
for for natural languages you can see
here like spanish and bulgarian
and this is the kind of at the end of
the
the presentation time so uh this is uh
this mind map
shows um the full um design
of the dsl systems each of this um
dsls like we're discussing data query
workflows in this presentation but the
others like say recommendations or
quantal regression or whatever
they're actually independent of course
it's very interesting to use them in
conjunction and together and obviously
they'll be sharing some
some of the codes right like say the
error handling operating you know like
misspellings and stuff and uh you know
like uh some
predicate handling and so forth but uh
it is
the one of the restrictions of one of
the assumptions is that this system
needs to be modular if you want to take
only one of these modules and develop it
further you should be able to do that
so this is related to my immediate
future plans
like i mean i mentioned many of those
i do wanna uh to have a to write a user
guide for this
one of the interesting things which
surprisingly it's hard to do i have done
it in mathematica by the way
is to produce random sentences of the
grammars they really help
learning the system all right so yeah
this is just another
another another demonstration using uh
different different machine learning
workflow i'm going to be teaching a
class maybe
i think it was approved i'm not entirely
sure i think it is
uh from uh with vol from you it's going
to be a short class of three four
lectures uh about this type of data
wrangling i was discussing right now
and here are the references for the
presentation yeah thank you for your
attention and i'm willing to answer
questions
looks like there is a question in the
partable chat okay
uh david de brother asks how important
is it to translate a data wrangling
request
into multiple different languages isn't
it sufficient to simply accomplish what
the user wants in just one language and
then return the result to the user
um this i mean if you grew up in
socialism and communism or any
totalitarian country yeah sure
but one of the reasons i moved to us is
exactly this to have choice
and so i actually think um the more you
the more you actually do this in
different languages i personally even if
i want to stay in language nobody lets
me
working with people different
generations different systems i need to
translate this into different
different programming languages another
thing is what in order to understand
your mountain
right you need to you need to climb the
mountain next to it
there's some other statements i mean
just a cliche
you know responses i have made so far on
this question but
there's something um you might have
heard like a low-level language is
a programming language is low level if
it uh makes you pay attention to
in unimportant details and this is
exactly kind of
this type of um this type of system
exposes
to what degree uh these languages and
packages have reduced increases so
from my perspective no i mean great
question i mean
i've been asking myself exactly this i
mean i wanted to stay involved from
language and i do
for me it's actually jello i mean in a
sense in order to kind of show that
voltron language is good and better you
need to do something like what i did
uh looks like we have a question in the
zoom chat uh
rodrigo moto says thanks for sharing
anton can you share the references
uh sure first of all this
i already uploaded this in the uh
this notebook what you see right now i
poured it into the
puffer ball but also you can very easily
find it in uh
as for i'm not sure what kind of
references you're looking for but
if you go to say uh github uh entered on
cube
i mean conversational agents is
something i'm doing quite a lot and
data running i'm doing quite a lot so
you can immediately land on some of the
pages
uh you know which discuss uh things and
how to do stuff and
what to load and etc
it doesn't look like there any more
questions so i just wanted to say thank
you everyone for coming and thank you
anton for a very informative talk
yeah thank you bye bye